Hey, David.
What happens if we tax the rich, too, much?
Do they leave the country do they stop
working?
Okay, so let's deal with this question again.
There's an idea that is sometimes presented
which is if you tax the rich, too, much, they
won't work
anymore because it won't be worth it for them
to the government takes too much of their
money, it's
not worth working or they will simply leave
the country.
Let's deal with these one by one.
First of all, if you tax rich people they
will leave the country anecdotally shore,
sometimes a rich
person changes where they live.
Sometimes it's for reasons related to taxation.
Sometimes it's not.
The truth is, the number of rich people that
would leave the United States, if taxes were
somewhat
higher.
We're not talking about I'm not at least talking
about a 90% marginal tax rate, starting at
a
million bucks.
I don't think that there's any evidence that
would be good.
The number of rich people who leave the
country is relatively small.
It's going to be more or less mathematically
in significant remember that most rich people
wanna
live in the place where they have community
where their families are, where they speak
the
language, sort.Some rich people might leave
if you tax them too much but not of the levels
at which
studies suggest the richest Americans should
be taxed.
So the leaving the country thing is really
quite a big distraction.
Now what about the possibility that if you
pack a rich person too, much, they
will stop working.
Here's the thing, you know how they say that
first million is the toughest that may or
may not be
true, depending on whether you inherited it,
or actually built a business, but the reality
is that in the
same way that there's a diminishing marginal
utility to money if you have a billion dollars,
another
5 million does very little for you if you
have a dollar, 5 million does a lot for you,
there's a
diminishing marginal utility for money.
But for a lot of these super rich people,
it's much easier to
build their wealth.
Then it maybe was to get to where they were.
Let me give you an example, if
you have a net worth of a billion dollars,
more than likely you can scale up your business
50%Relatively easily compared to starting
a business from scratch, so if you're being
taxed for
example, at the 73% marginal tax rate on income
above 10 million, that means if you go from
a
billion a year in income to 11 billion a year
in income right?
Imagine you grow your business.
million, you might pay 73% on that additional
100 million but the relative amount of work
that was
required to get that additional hundred million
was far smaller than it was to build your
business to
its first 100 million.
So there's no question that if you tax the
super rich 95% marginal tax rate
above a certain level, that likely would be
a disincentive to continue working, if it's
as most studies
suggest you wanna top it out around 70 or
73% at very high incomes, it is very unlikely
that it will
have a significant effect in terms of getting
rich people to abandon work.
And in fact the idea is that
balancing everything a top marginal tax rate
around 70% would maximize government revenue.
It
accounts for the fact that some people may
actually work less if they find out that their
top income
is gonna be taxed at 70%, but even accounting
for that it is going to generate the most
revenue for
the government.
We can debate whether it's ethical we can
debate whether it's fair, I'm fine having
that debate, but to argue that rich people
are simply going to leave the country or that
rich people
03/13/20 Page 16 of 18
davidpakmanshow­2020­03­13­commercialfree
are going to stop working.
If we put in place something like a 70% top
marginal tax rate, it's simply
not backed by the data I've seen, if you have
different data I should look at, let me know
and I'm
glad to review and change my mind if the data
warrants that.
We have a great bone.
And so for you today, make sure you are signed
up for a membership, a joint
patent dot com, you will be treated to a producer
Pat posted bonus to today, and then I will
be back
with you on the bones show, in a the David
patent show at David pack.
men to come